oh let me comment on this Bobbie Lee who
obviously named after general robert e
lee and a lot of you gotta know Bobby
Lee's a beautiful um Korean or semi
Korean comedian and he has a podcast
called Tigers belly which is also a rare
food I think it's a rare food and it's
also a nickname for diarrhea which is
then a nickname for Nick Swardson but
I'm gonna tell you Bobby Lee decided to
uh drop a little oh my yeah which is
French and also I think is a cheese to a
boy by getting the same haircut so Bobby
you want to step out here new to my
territory bruh that's what I'm seeing
here but let me tell you that it's not
just a this which you wandered into
Robert is not just a style man it's an
embodiment of something bigger than
yourself do this it's that BYO Tarzan
bro it's like having something just
swinging off the back of you you know
what I'm singing dude anybody could just
have hair think tons of things have hair
dude even some women have a little bit
of hair on their chin bruh you know and
they might work at the library or
whatever but what I'm telling you Robert
or Bobby as you go by which is obviously
a racist name but I'm telling you this
Bobby that you can't just just try to
embody my [ __ ] follicle karate bra
you feel me
you can't just try and duplicate my
gaiter cape baby okay cuz you hear when
I turn my head you hear that [ __ ]
[Music]
you hear that tail flip around bro that
thing that thing will bite a baby at
Disneyworld Brian playing this hair
cutting playing Robert and I saw you the
other day Bobby and you look like rosie
o donnell that's what she was looking
like man with your long hair I seen it
and now you're trying to come at your
boy and the slept Kingdom was to
challenge the rat kingdom well let me
just tell you little daddy that this is
a working man's cut this isn't one of
these sleeping cuts that you like your
hair before it woulda tested positive
for tempur-pedic miss what I'm saying
isn't it you're gonna have to wake up
Bobby
because the haircut you have now that
you've grown in that you come into this
adult men's haircut before you had a
children's cut you know kind of a thick
child maybe that it uh never done well
on standardized tests and then was put
into a unique school for children that
learn more by shapes and by you know
soft items but now you have a real
señores haircut man a man's cut and this
is a full-bodied style you know this
thing has aroma coming off of it you
know you got that haircut now man I look
I'll tell you sometimes I turn around
and they'll be six raccoons behind me
and two of them doing dice bruh and one
of them's cutting up a ground so it's
just you're entering a realm that I
don't know if you're prepared for and I
don't know if you're welcome well thanks
for watching that video right there that
was a beautiful little segment I think
but of course i'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribers curse
card